bonsoir heureux de vous recevoir
ravi de vous recevoir ça fait un an que
je vous attends non que quoi que tu es
dur de partout je suis dur de partout ça
va ça va bien merci
et elles ont un nom j'aurais plutôt n'y
arriverai jamais tous les deux aller à
cette préliminaire
[Musique]
m
comment tu conserves qui adore ça ne
m'étonne pas comment tu trouves tu vois
ça va je trouve bien fera même pas le
morceau
rien de la chanson
m
et
en france
ça vous plaît fred tout ce qui peut
danser je prends ouais moi c'est une
chose que j'aurais préféré faire toute
la vie si possible enfin bien entendu
médiéviste vous êtes auteur de romans
policiers pour être en plus danseuse ah
bah non
un manque de danseuses médiéviste cela
il ya un manque mais strip teaseuse
médiéviste une demande sept mais laurent
beaucoup et tu sais que suis un amoureux
de la musique et maintenant je pense que
c'est un disque qui restera
bah j'aime beaucoup ouais c'est tout
faux pas c'est pas vous chantiez bien
comme ça merci bien entendu chanter
comme ça fait quand j'étais jeune je
faisais du piano depuis l'âge de 6 ans
et plus ce teaser d'une cour à l'école
donc c'est vrai qu'on chantait pas mal
de choses me reprenait des chansons
genre starmania qui était très dur à
chanter mais comme on était enfant on
apprend que vite
ouais ça va bien c'est bien ainsi je
pense pouvoir
vim
une petite consolation dans ce métier
quand même hein donc après greg le
millionnaire l'été dernier tf1 proposait
cet été marjolaine et les millionnaires
dont vous aviez comme ça une quinzaine
de mecs autour de vous quinze garçons 1
ce qui est très bizarre c'est que la
personne qui a présenté l'émission cette
année c'est greg greg le millionnaire
qui est qui revenu ça s'était pas très
bien passé avec vous l'été dernier oui
parce qu'en fait j'ai été on va dire
éjecté en quatrième
ouais je pensais rester un peu plus
longtemps ouais que j'étais un peu déçu
il avait choisi marica oui j'ai loupé le
rôle voilà non mais vous étiez folle de
rage parce que vous avez été rarement
jeté par un mec vous ça m'est pas arrivé
ouais et
et finalement en fait c'est une bonne
expérience parce qu'après on arrive à un
peu plus à vous étiez énervé vous l'avez
traité de truffes greg c'est pas très
sympa mais vous le connaissiez avant en
fait vous aviez rencontré dans les
boîtes de nuit c'est un garçon qui fait
qu'on est au milieu de la nuit
parisienne
donc comme moi je fréquente aussi ce
milieu là je l'avais déjà croisé mais
sans vraiment avoir discuté dessus alors
ce qui s'est passé je sais pas si vous
avez suivi l'année dernière greg le
millionnaire à l'aide mais il ya un
moment il s'enferme peu et dans une
chambre vous claquer la porte au nez des
caméras et elle s'est il passé dans la
chambre
vous voulez savoir ce qui le séduit lui
nous a dit sa version quand il est venu
ici nous a dit sa version lui et qu'est
ce qu'il a dit il a dit que c'est
dépassé un truc
ah oui mais quoi ça commence par ph
pourquoi photo fellation quand tu
n'écris pas les péages
bah écoutez gilles parent et répond à
cette question pourquoi est ce que parce
que je trouve que en fait ce qui est
beau c'est c'est de laisser place à la
nature
je trouve que c'est ça qui est beau
parce qu'en fait du stuff suis mr ouai
et j'essaie d'entretenir sa est toujours
je trouve que ça marche pas mal ça
marche bien bon alors donc cette année
vous étiez avec les quinze mecs à la fin
vous avez choisi j'aurais même pourquoi
lui que je sache un peu ce qui peut vous
intéresser
bah déjà sept grâces ont je crois qu'on
a fait le moins par rapport aux
mensonges et que j'ai senti en fait le
plus vrai pour les autres je sais pas
comme quelque chose même s'il me
racontais toutes ces choses là il ya
quand même l'instinct féminin qui en moi
qui parlais
non par rapport à ça je me suis guidé et
je crois que j'ai eu raison
alors ouais ouais mais ça vous intéresse
vous vous regardez ça fred vargas je
trouve que 15 c'est beaucoup pour vous
décider dans la vie quinze garçons mais
en fait on avait très peu de temps et le
si on avait pris plus de garçons on
n'aurait pas eu vraiment le temps de
l'étudier dernier n'avait donc c'est
plus simple de faire dans la vie normale
mais s'est pas pliée normal ah pardon
parce que voilà et puis dieu et puis de
démission voilà bien qui est une
émission bien qu'ils aient quelque chose
à la télévision entre deux spots de pub
il faut bien qu'on va mettre un
programme après
ce qu'il faut savoir quand même ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que vous aviez le
choix entre joan où cinquante mille
euros et que vous avez choisi johan
c'est beau si vous êtes quand même
touché après les 50000 euros
bah disons que par la suite moral de
morat oui oui l'apprenant fait à trouver
jusque comme j'avais bien réagi que bon
j'avais changé que j'avais fait
énormément d'efforts et que c'est vrai
que je rejoigne n'avait pas énormément
de moyens ils ont pensé que les 50000
euros allait nous aider en fait à être
un peu plus déjà un peu est ce que vous
êtes toujours ensemble bah écoute et on
essaie de faire le possible mais c'est
vrai que juste après le tournage j'ai dû
enchaîner avec le vidéoclip à cuba tu
dis enregistré moncigale enfin je suis
pas mal de un emploi du temps assez
chargé
c'est pas évident mais j'essaie de faire
le maximum mais aussi sa montre
actuellement vous n'êtes pas obligé
vis-à-vis de la chaîne 2 2 non je suis
resté avec lui
non disons que nous ont aidés à nous
rencontrer mais c'est vrai que par la
suite après c'est chacun évolue là vous
êtes toujours un petit peu ensemble oui
encore ben disons qu'on n'arrive pas
trop à joints les emplois de temps parce
que c'est un peu chargé pour moi mais on
essaye paris où c'est pas vrai que la
part de mystère comme médiateur au
niveau de votre histoire avec sugar
oui c'est vrai d'accord ah oui c'est
vrai c'est pas de la comédie
non là d'accord c'est pas le genre de si
je puis me permettre c'est pas le genre
de marjolaine ça s'est pas agi comme ça
mais je pense pas que dans le théâtre
puisse attacher des vrais sentiments en
externe qu on fait juste une
interprétation savannah voir sincère là
par exemple avec moi là la wii mais très
sincère alors vous êtes toujours
ensemble ce qui est assez rare parce que
vous avez vu que tous les couples de la
télé-réalité c'est fini la brandon et
diana c'est fini greg et marika aussi
l'argot et qu'on jalousie viennent de 4
est mieux fait de choisir vous greg
parce qu'avec marica c'est fini olivier
le bachelor avec sandra c'est fini aussi
vous saviez tout ça ferait de la en tous
les cas ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il
ya eu dans télé 7 jours un sondage les
olympiades de la séduction de l'été 2004
numéro un
marjo
la toile est là tu vois comment mon pote
le chauffeur de salle sa fédé ça fait
des cendres ça fait battus veut la
touche et oui on voit on voit la pousse
bisiaux voilà plus bisous
non mais merci anthérieu s'est fait un
nom qui me parlent de toi j'arrête pas
je suis fâché je sais déjà bombay
physique havre on laisse tomber à l'eau
peut-être que peut-être que j'ai une
chance de repartir avec avec marc
chollet pourquoi parce que je suis
grattée le milliardaire peut-être que tu
vas avoir cette chance de repartir avec
moi ce soir
ah oui tiens une petite pique pour
gratter fait s'ils allaient marjo
tu va repartir avec des morpions c'est
bon
c'est plutôt par et tient bon mais je
repart bredouille sans marjo sans pognon
alors je lève
vous avez déclaré pour me séduire il
faut être sincère honnête et pas ici de
montcuq l'est est ce qu'une fois qu'on
vous a séduit ça peut se discuter après
j'ai déclaré qu'à moi j'ai fait un petit
listing vos déclarations
je suis vicieuse vous maintenant oui je
suis vicieuse mais en fait en ce moment
depuis peu temps j'essaie d'être une
fille bien lisse et ça mais j'ai du mal
elle a déclaré une chienne a besoin d'un
mètre et j'ai dit qu'une chaîne avait
besoin d'un mail mais je n'ai pas dit
que j'étais une chaîne non mais j'ai pas
dit que vous étiez une chaîne donc j'ai
dit ça ouais vous avez dit en revanche
c'est pas parce qu'une fille parle de
cul que c'est une chienne ça c'est vrai
je pense aujourd'hui on est quand même
en l'an 2000 cadres donc je pense que
deux jeunes femmes vous n'avez pas
écouté la suite de ce que je voulais
dire
j'ai pas vu le temps passer
et vous laisser je pensais pas qu'il
était si tard je veux dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est en 2004 et qui est
bon une fille peut très bien parlé de
choses sexuelles comme les garçons sans
être pour autant une fille voilà qui est
malheureux
alors vous avez déclaré aussi l'amour
c'est n'importe où n'importe quand avec
n'importe qui ça s'excite ça excite à
serrer dans le journal la croix
alors les départs tous je vous dit j'ai
eu des expériences mais je suis pas une
grande adepte un départ tout c'est pas
votre passé 50
ben non je fais face off ça dépend
chacun fait ce qu'il veut en fait s'en
va vous c'est pas votre truc quoi non
pas trop vous dites je ne suis pas une
[ __ ] je suis comme ma génération
ouverte d'esprit est le même les photos
ouverte d'esprit il y avait des esprits
mais je n'ai pas vu d'esprit je suis
désolé oui en tous les cas moi je trouve
qu une fille comme vous c'est très
bloquant pour un mec c'est vrai niveau
des tarifs non si tu trouves pas certes
une fille très libérée comme ça c'est
bloquant pour un mail du ministre
quelque part les ministres ont toujours
revendiqué une grande liberté sexuelle
savoir par exemple qu'en ce moment aux
états unis à des grands mouvements de
féministes qui se bat pour que les
femmes aient un cinéma du des films
pornos pour elle c'est vrai inquiets
qu'ils disent pourquoi nous on n'aurait
pas le droit aussi de se caresser dans
le noir comme les garçons dans l'est
dans les cinémas donc les féministes
sont pas forcément des dames
patronnesses tu trouves pas que c'est
bloquant pour un mec une fille comme ça
j'ai pas l'impression - ne bloque pas
trop petit post bizuths serge à aller
à l'aide ça vous fait peur une fille
comme ça vaut imaginez bien que je
drague et pas d'autres filles que votre
famille imaginait ne rompent pas du tout
ça vous bloquerait pas vous non parce
qu'on allait prendre un pot a pas
l'émission ça tableaux créés ou non pas
du tout je suis avec un quand même mais
c'est vrai on vit dans un monde c'est
vrai on sait l'évolution enfin moi je
viendrai méfiez-vous travers quand même
m
[Musique]
je sais pas pour vous draguer par
exemple qu'est ce qui fait dire est ce
que il faut dire par exemple je pourrais
me tuer pour toi je sais pas ça dépend
du 4 ça dépend ouais qu'elle étudierait
quoi laurent si tu devais la drague et
bat pas grand chose visiblement je
prendrai mon tour
pour la draguer tu es belle comme un
soleil quand je te vois je bronze
je sais pas jamais dragué dans la vie
ouais je crois que sa femme regarde bien
moi je vous trouve merveilleuse ya ce
bon le problème des saints mais savent
pas son âge
pardon mais ça c'est bien trois
problèmes
c'est un salon c'est pas ça du tout fait
asseoir avec nous mais line avant non
c'est que marjo s'est fait refaire les
seins à l'âge de 18 ans et c'était con
parce que finalement si vous l'aviez pas
fait vous auriez eu quand même une très
belle poitrine et voilà mais je crois
ouais enfin je sais pas parce qu'à
l'époque j'étais un petit peu rebelle
dont je voulais un peu
ouais je sais pas ça ça a pris un coup
de folie comme ça maintenant vous
regretter un peu l'histoire des saints
je regrette pas mais disons que je suis
une personne qui prend à des coups de
feu dit à l'effet que cherche une
personnage c'est comme ça c'est spontané
impatiente comme voilà vous êtes un peu
piégé nord avec ses salles non parce que
je te pas mal de gens me disent qu'ils
sont bien et qui est beau c'est pas plus
dérangeant alors on dit toujours vous
êtes intéressé par l'argent en fait pas
du tout parce que tout ce que vous
gagnez la télé réalité je tiens à le
dire
c'est uniquement de l'argent de poche
j'vous de famille un peu d'argent quand
même oui c'est de l'argent que j'utilise
pour on va dire pour me faire plaisir
pour voyager faire des cadeaux à des
amis donc c'est pas des choses parce que
pour moi l'argent c'est fait pour vivre
dans le confort et faire plaisir aux
autres
ouais qu'est ce que c'est laurent un
cadeau
oh que c'est beau
[Musique]
bravo laurent jeanne du lot qui va avec
aq à la culotte aussi qu'est ce qui a
été fait sur la culotte pour pénétrer
[Musique]
non
aliochine romanga terre et puis souvent
sapin en combi j'attends je vous dis
c'est vrai dans mon cas j'avais pas mon
single
voilà deux raisons voilà voilà
[Musique]
alors donc je disais que j'avais de
l'argent de famille est d'ailleurs
l'appartement occupé près des
champs-elysées la voiture tout ça s'est
payé par vos parents en fait oui
s'occupe de mangues séchées encore jeune
j'ai pas encore vraiment un métier
bah oui mais voilà donc vos parents
s'occupent de vous vous êtes une petite
fille en fait alors votre père était
ministre vietnamien à la base il était
industriels et comme c'était une des
puissances économiques les plus
importants du pays celle à qui est
devenu bras droit du président il a aidé
au niveau conseil économique
ouais voilà et donc vous êtes riche on
peut le dire moi je suis pas riche
disons que mon père a beaucoup travaillé
pour ses 14 enfants soient bien dans le
bien non le confrère on va dire dans
tous les cas vous avez dit le premier
pauvre que j'ai rencontrés c'était greg
c'était une boutade
vous avez fait des études 1 oui des
études bac s
c'est physique chimie skype à mon père
il voulait que chaque médecin sort était
bien joué je suis dur de partout on va
voir sa vie malaisé de suite un peu trop
dur et trop longue
donc voilà j'ai un parti dans l'âme
voilà ensuite et ce mode et le cours
florent voilà alors c'est vrai qu'on a
un petit peu marre moi je trouve qu'on
vous fasse toujours passer pour une
bimbo elle est belle en fait vous allez
vraiment quelque chose dans la tête
c'est bien que l'on visualise cuit mais
disons que je suis pas sortir trop de
conneries parce que je sais que des fois
on est vite juger on a tous une
étiquette
donc voilà j'ai vite mais voilà donc
pour savoir ce que vous avez dans la
tête
on va faire une interview marjolaine
citoyenne
[Musique]
je lève
est-ce que vous votez pas la star ac
est-ce que vous voter aux élections
j'explique
est-ce que vous votiez
non je ne dors pas vous votez pas c'est
quoi votre position sur les 35 heures
moi je trouve que c'est un wc répondent
s'il vous plaît je trouve que ça un
programme qui a été établi pour un
ensemble de gens et d'industrie qui ne
fonctionne pas forcément dans le même
système
ouais voilà voilà donc vous pensez qu'il
faut s'adapter voilà il faut s'adapter
en fonction
vous parlez comme antoine seillières non
mais tu vois c'est pas la peine d'aller
d'aller chercher ces hier le baron
seillière même physiquement les deux
reprises dans certaines industries qu il
a appliqué la loi des 35 heures voilà
c'est fait est ce que vous pensez qu'on
puisse revenir au plein emploi en france
pourquoi au plein emploi ça tient c'est
à dire que tout le monde ait du travail
et chômage n'ont pas dit qu au sein de
chômeurs reflète pas sa tête passe à
juger on en fait pas ça comme ça là mais
moi j'arrive plus à poser des questions
je pense que
je sais pas ce serait bien d'avoir le
plein d'un poids me le prendre c'est que
c'est impossible c'est impossible c'est
impossible
ces ventes mais l'impossible la baisse
d'impôt sur les sociétés vous en pensez
quoi
ce serait bien peu se comme ça ça évite
la délocalisation des sociétés en france
le nom nathan ya des mecs qui sont
ministres et franchement les trois
quarts avaient dit la même chose et une
société se délocalise parce que elles
payent trop d'impôts alors il ya trop de
lois pour les et du coup bah vous êtes
une étrangeté libye voilà qu'est ce que
vous pensez des mesures de
défiscalisation des droits de succession
qu'a lancé sarkozy la semaine dernière
ça peut être intéressant que c'est comme
ça ça et vite
peut-être aux gens de faire des montages
plus qu' il faut des montages illégaux
et puis finalement la fin en fait ils
soient à voir donc qu'en initiant de
justement de favoriser ce serait vain
mais qu'est ce que tu penses de montage
et de l'ego chef moi je tenais dans
l'exigence légale est ce que en termes
d'insécurité chronique est plutôt
favorable à la prévention ou à la
répression
[ __ ] la prévention à la prévention
vous pensez quoi des lois sarkozy sur la
sécurité intérieure
moi ce que je comprends pas c'est que
sarkozy laminé normes sécurité à paris
alors que justement le problème n'est
pas à paris en banlieue parisienne
puisque gens qui sont à paris travaille
donc 90% c'est pas des gens qui vous
fait oublier comment vous le problème
des banlieues déjà six de leurs
leur permettre des logements un peu plus
salubres parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
quand même des logements insalubres
et des à l'emploi et surtout au lieu de
les réprimer considérée comme une
mauvaise population contraire les aider
à chercher un emploi et démotivés quoi
franchement canon mais servent que c'est
parfait est-ce que comme on dit beaucoup
en ce moment vous pensez que les
islamistes sont déjà là je pense qu'ils
ont toujours été là mais c'est que
jusqu'à présent on n'avait jamais parlé
aujourd'hui on met le sujet d'actualité
donc la pacification de l'irak voyez ça
comment marjolaine chipeau penser que ce
sera possible
je pense pas parce que d'un point de vue
économique enfin tout le monde sait que
la guerre en irak s'étaient d'un point
de vue économique il s'en foutait de du
sort des irakiens ce qu'ils voulaient
c'était le pétrole qui étaient là bas
donc quand les états unis avaient besoin
d'une règle enfin d'une d'une chute au
niveau économique et de remonter ensuite
ils ont fait la guerre en irak
quand vous voyez plutôt pour bush lui
pour kerry vous pour qui bouche ou kerry
kirill était pour la paix vous voulez
vous feriez présent pour bush va taper
en touche moi je suis contre bush je
suis totalement contre
mais plutôt pour kerry alors oui oui
d'accord du parce que c'est pas bouche
c'est tout ne sais pas si vous êtes
sensible aux doigts des photos aux
droits des femmes
salah
question très très belle question vous
êtes sensible aux doigts des femmes au
droit du sein à redire ce ver qui peut
jouer sérieusement oui oui moi je suis
sensible et pioche est-ce que vous
pensez que raymond domenech et est
capable de redresser l'équipe de france
je sais pas je m'intéresse pas trop en
ce moment aux sports ne suffit pas le
temps je pourrais pas répondre c'était
une bonne idée vous prier de faire
débuter pires contre israël n'est pas
s'excuser à propos d'israël vous pensez
quoi du conflit israélo palestinien
bah ça je pense que ça restera tout le
temps est toujours parce qu'un gars de
religion et des territoires c'est off
depuis depuis très longtemps on sait que
c'est un solide
ouais je pense pas marjolaine
politologue incroyable espère une
émission j'arrive vraiment un
et là je trouve que sur le plan
intellectuel vous est parfaite
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus